hello everyone uh welcome to another
wolf language design review we I think
we may have skipped a few because of our
summer school and other things but we're
back
this is part of our incremental language
development series
and
I have a feeling co-map maybe a rather
long discussion
um uh so there are few trades ref Pages
for the preliminary implementation of
co-map and codemap apply
um am I ever going to remember what
comap does head map so there's a section
there on naming actually I remember we
discussed it at length the very first
time we talked about it was in 2015 so
it's been something that's been circling
around for a little bit
um
yeah so Ian's collected some notes Here
on its relationship to category Theory
because that was something you had a
little bit of a concern about
um and what's the answer I mean is there
a term is there a coma Concept in
category Theory
no
okay
good
this is basically mapping a functional
and map maps of function maps of
function
what about a term like operator map
given that operator is our kind of
functional
yeah that could work
offhand it's I mean unless there's
something ruling it out it does seem
better than comap I I just can't
remember what comap does
well so here the operator would be the
argument right it's a particular kind of
functional it's just evaluating a
function at a point
why is the argument order this way
around
because
we want to have functions themselves in
the in the first argument but this isn't
what's happening wait that first yeah
not the first example doesn't look right
it seems wrong you know it's reversed
it's reversed
so this is the wrong way around so I
would hopefully be able to do this
not at work yes okay it was the wrong
way around that was really really
confusing me yeah I didn't notice that
so
what are our other functions that do you
know we talk about the operator form of
things but what are our names for
we don't really name the operator forms
do we
but that's again different yet again
different I mean an operator form for us
is something where everything's packed
in the head so to speak
of the applied family
yeah some of those
does this have a one argument form
yes
it has an operator form
I don't even understand what this is
doing because this is
oh I see this is taking this thing
this is a confusing example if I might
say so I mean if I were to just see
co-map
of fgh comma X
that's what I want to see
for a basic example yeah I would pay not
to have a list to not have a list as the
second argument I mean that example is
just crazy and hopefully the future as
rough page doesn't no it's a good
example Stephen it's just not a good
basic one it's an example of why women
want to use it but it's not an example
exactly what the heck it's doing yeah
I mean I think that's a great
application example yes basic stats
this the first example here is exactly
right
okay
yeah I mean these are not bad
can you update your documentation
um
well this does seem fairly reasonable
I'm beginning to the co-map name it was
you know by the time this was two lists
and the argument order was wrong I was
pretty confused
but this is making more sense to me
I'm still thinking though operator map
might be
um
more
clear to your uh but I I don't I I
dislike operator map right because in
the sense map is operator map right yeah
you give an operator in the first an
operator form in the first thing and it
Maps it across the arguments
I think we should put in come up as an
experimental function and just see if
any of us can remember what it does
this is a bit like the through function
which I means a lot right yeah one of
the alternate names for it in the past
was actually composed through because if
you have through of compose of heads you
get this but yeah except through has not
generally been a successful function
yes it is a useful function but not
necessarily not an easy one thing
I want to say co-map and co-map apply
together cover the same functionality is
through
I'd probably use comap instead of
through if it were available so hey by
the way something is wrong with my uh
docs update and I guess we have to let
Roger now
um this is not working
let me just um send in mail and somebody
should be okay please the version of The
Ref page you had is all right but it I
don't think it's yeah I know but I'm a
little bit worried about what this is
doing God knows it might be it might be
overwriting everything so um
uh
let me just just could you just tell
somebody tell Roger that this is um I've
sent him a screenshot of what it's doing
I'm going to kill the process
I'm suspicious though okay so co-map and
co-map apply
are going to um
uh
let's do it the experimental functions
that wasn't so hard was it no we we got
rid of that topic quicker than anybody
would have thought
yeah probably jump to the third section
here since we have Michael for some
unlimited time or if you really want to
talk about jury intermediate well I mean
it might be easy let's take a look
it's not going to be very easy because
there are some some interesting
extensions
okay all right okay
so this is the uh selection of chat GPT
suggested visualization functions that
um Brett and I looked at and that he
thinks are this is a pretty is Brett
here yeah
this looks like a pretty reasonable idea
yeah I mean the polar ones for sure
that's a useful thing as a function of
as a function of r and Theta
I mean you can do it can't you buy
uh uh what do you actually need to do
you need to do
a region fund what the heck is that
weird Branch Cutty type thing it's
probably an artifact of something
I'm not sure
yeah
right well that's a good reason to have
the function so it doesn't have stuff
like that because we've actually figured
it out
but I'm going to ask the question so
what would I do in this case in the case
of like a a vessel function thing the
whole point is I can give the
coordinates I mean so
yeah it does seem like a reasonable
thing to have
any any objections to this one
I think it's very useful one yeah I
think both of the Polar ones are are
reasonably nice examples
so I don't know what a polar histogram
is if unless it's you know
why why wouldn't this be like
a different View
of a different a different layout on of
histogram of histogram
um
uh some of the options would be would be
different it would you want the polar
frame and polar axes
um
but so how do I specify the polar
histogram so what I've got is a bunch of
theta values basically
and I'm going to make a histogram based
on those data values but I understand
why this thing is is puffing outwards as
it goes further out
is that what you would expect
I guess it has no choice that's just
more area around and more perimeter
around the circle
the question uh why why are certain you
know why why are they only one two three
different or four different uh well I've
seen those are just it's a small data
set video it has you know one two or
three things I would guess
yeah no I guess those are real valued so
okay right but it's still discrete
counts in each bit
because it's starting to otherwise in
other respects it looks like a pie chart
and this one is implemented using you
know a variant on pie chart okay all
right
um
the whole point is that you're being
thrown a bunch of theta values you're
not being thrown a I mean in a bar chart
you're being told his or a sector chart
you're being told or pie chart rather
you're being told here are the
here are the widths of the pie elements
yeah this is a completely different
thing
okay this does seem reasonable
this is a bizarre use of of AIS what a
strange use
I think it's going to be difficult to
see Zero values
that's a good point
so I wonder whether this should start
with some fixed radius well maybe that's
an option
I mean it's certainly possible to
do something like that well negative
value is your toast
it's a histogram you can't have negative
values
well good point but boy we met zero
values then likewise just gaps like this
right
[Music]
yes but is it possible to appreciate
there how many
are jumping
so we're skipping well there's nothing
there would be if you had radial if you
had radial lines there for every I mean
you could imagine having something where
every bin I mean I don't understand why
these bins are of different widths that
doesn't make a lot of sense to me
see what I'm saying I would expect that
the thing would have every 10 degrees
there'd be all the thetas in those 10
degrees yeah perhaps that's their
problem perhaps we need some
intermediate lines between
Stephen's saying is that all those
sectors should have the same central
angle exactly
but at which point you can kind of see
there's a gap of that size just like you
could see on a standard histogram you
could see oh there's this region of the
x-axis that has nothing in it
I think that will solve itself I mean
there's a separate issue which we don't
tend to need to have an ordinary
histogram and I doubt we'll need here
which is kind of separated lines between
the positions of the different bars
you don't need that and I bet you won't
need it and this is just a bad example
right
yeah the reference examples are Maybe
easier to look at this is just something
I happen to have that was doing
effectively a polar histogram
I can't really tell completely but I
mean those what we we know what this is
supposed to look like yes but you saw
that the third one had a
I mean the third one is nuts
but but it starts without with a fixed
non-zero radius
I think if you are interested in this
green very small
because your point is that by the time
you're down here these things are very
tiny exactly yeah yeah so probably we
want
something called I don't know origin
radius or some such other thing we
already have sector origin
what does that mean
it does pretty much exactly what Jose is
describing
okay you know what can you see the fact
that that silly raft is running away
from me again I keep on objecting to the
same thing can we make sure this is
covered in the um
uh user assistance meeting
okay yeah we'll make sure Carla passes
that along oh wow look those are old
colors
what oh yeah that's an old styling
that's the original V7
color scheme for sector chart and pie
chart so you mean if I run this again
it'll be different
is it better now
well anyway okay this is the sector
origin
yeah I think this is exactly what that
was yeah that's exactly what's needed
yep
okay
should this be called polar histogram or
sector histogram
probably total histograms I think polar
fine let's go with the go with the bot
we're back here in six months where yeah
the bot has just made this up 25 million
more times
okay sanky diagrams yeah yeah yeah
people ask for this with some regularity
we actually have the cousin the
Louisville diagram in the wfr
what exactly is this I'm not familiar
with this with this name
so so this is showing
flow from you know between different
states by volume
yeah so like your left hand you know
the trendy use for these is you know
you're you on the your left you have
like your income and your job and you
have you know your parents are giving
you an allowance or inheritance or
something
and then you sort of show what your
income is and where it goes and your
expenses and you know what you're paying
for rent and food and your Investments
and car insurance and uh-huh it's a club
for your purposes it's a graph
but it's a graph which has
it's a very weighted graph
right
and let me look up I guess yeah
bipartite yes exactly
um
directed and bipartite
not necessarily by Parkside it could be
uh the way it's laid out it is but yes
you're correct because you could have
the same names on the uh on either
vertical well I know what I mean is that
you'll sometimes see multiple vertical
things that
you you go from this to that to the
other thing
um okay so yeah sequence
it's a bunch of countries and for each
country it's a bunch of items
but you could you could actually
consider countries to items to countries
in terms of um
uh import export
it's kind of fun I didn't know this was
um since I've just been writing about
this the history of the second North
thermodynamics
it um
ah
so this is interesting I think there's a
triangle in the top left
right you've got three vertices forming
a triangle
this is a little different than this I
mean this is this is being
um you still have the property of you
know conservation of weight going in and
weight going out yes
okay so let's just talk about okay we
also need to understand the soluville
diagram thing
what is this now
what does this mean
what is this this is I see this is
stages
what is this exactly
I don't remember what this is doing
well okay let's look at this one first
of all
um
okay so what does the proposal here's
the proposal to use weighted edges
or something
I mean if I run this okay
and I just say
I don't quite understand could I just
make a random graph here
I don't think an arbitrary random graph
would work at least you know probably
not for that code
what
by the way could somebody report it
again yet again these stupid messages
are going here this is some bug with
docu tools
make make who's pmming here uh me I I'll
be checking checking that yeah that's I
mean it's being actively investigated
okay all right fine
okay so this
you want to say something like rule
triple at this
and then we want to live incredibly
dangerously and say thank you diagram of
that
is that not a work of art
it is
it's lovely
uneven useful
wow I think the main thing this is
missing is the as you're saying the
weights are the widths of the
uh the link right but in this particular
case so so the thing we'd want to do is
one is sort of histogramology of having
I don't know whether we want to we want
to be able to decide whether we merge
two things if we have one goes to three
and we have two items of that so to
speak
is what I'm saying we might want to
merge them either visibly or invisibly
but otherwise these things here I would
have thought
that we should support three syntaxes
you know arrows edges director
undirected edges
and
and also
you know something like because you know
we've got directed Edge
of 1 3.5 for example
which is a weighted directed Edge
and that will be a really nice thing to
be able to have is take this get this
diagram from a graph
but then we should also support the form
1 4.5 just like that I think
so that's you know two from I mean from
Two and wait
so yes both multigraphs and weighted
graphs
yes
what happens if I just do this I don't
know I've never tried this
it will probably treat 1 4 as a vertex
ah oh no
um well yes it did yes oh no no it
treated it as an edge
right
okay so now if I do this with
0.6
0.2
I think that should work I don't see any
reason why that shouldn't work
that's something for Charles and Friends
okay yeah we'll pass that along
do you agree that should work I mean it
seems useful to me well I mean graph
yeah it's a statement that you know
vertices can be anything right
yeah but this is not this is not
treating vertices as anything here
it's really more edges yeah well I mean
right I mean the question is which way
should it should there be weights or
should that be no no this is the correct
thing this is the correct thing there's
nothing else this could be there's an
outlet here what's that edge weights
yeah there's got to be Edge weights are
does undirected Edge take the
the three argument form yes yes
yeah I mean this should be equivalent
this thing here just like this thing
here is undirected Edge of two arguments
equivalent to that this should be
equivalent to the three argument form
it's just an oversight what is a for the
purposes of Sankey diagram how to handle
negative weights
for the purposes of of a graph how do we
handle negative weights I think we just
put a maybe we have a dotted line that's
what I was thinking actually in the run
it in the middle and
use the width or weights
perhaps well perhaps stop the whole
thing if we wanted to I mean that's a
style at least
the height the height of the bars on the
sides will be tricky with negative
weights
right the one and the two left overlap
somehow oh yeah well I you know I don't
think negative weights are the biggest
priorities it's an edge case
uh yeah okay kick him from the meeting
so
um
we we could actually just have those
Heights um equal to you know related to
the number of edges
no you right it should be why I mean
that the height should corresponds why
isn't this symmetrical
um what did you do sorry complete did
the complete graph on five edges I think
it's not right I think it's a bug but
anyway it's not a big deal
what is Edge list for that complete
graph
I mean I'm guessing it has like one or
two but not too much look absolutely
magnificent but
oh oh oh I see what the problem is the
problem is it is this Edge list because
they're undirected edges
right
yeah they're ordered right yeah yeah so
in fact the correct thing to do here
would be to say
you know uh join hash and reverse of
hash
or you could just say direct it graph
directed graph concentrate
I'm still confused perhaps the Symmetry
is left to right you see how the sizes
are decreasing on the left and
increasing on the right yes there is
some sort of combined symmetry
up down left right
the main point is these are very you
didn't reverse though right you you
reverse the whole list you didn't
reverse the individual elements
silly me
that's better yes that looks that's
lovely these are really nice I mean
about the black on the right I don't
understand that why isn't it it's just a
default color scheme is if you go up and
change the definition why not why not
use that same coloring I don't
understand why the coloring of
of why the why this isn't one coloring
over here if you understand what I'm
saying
this is a simple prototype it's not yeah
okay fine right and certainly in the
general case
right the left and right things will be
completely different so it's not clear
to them you don't want to use the same
colors on the right it gets very
confusing because the receipt it's the
receiving end of multiple colors each of
those blocks right also another point is
that I think in many cases
you may want to I'm not sure you want to
rotate the one two three fours to be
reading this way around if you get what
I'm saying
we want the same orientation maybe maybe
these are lovely though these are great
diagrams we should absolutely have these
and I even like the color scheme
okay awesome
um they have this resemblance to a lot
of code I have looked at over the years
some of it some of it my own well I mean
this is relevant the the name Sankey
diagram is a bit obscure although it is
what they're usually called but it's
going to be relevant to like string
diagrams and tensor manipulation and so
on don't you think Jose and others
um
perhaps yes
because this is showing like if you're
you know
take two senses by the way this is a
good start it's gonna say I've certainly
seen like
diffuse between files where
you know one line got you know turned
into three and so you have a little
widening
you know spline type thing connecting
them right
um I think this is great and I think the
fact that we can take a graph I mean by
the way the Sankey diagram should be
able to take a graph as input
I wonder uh Brett what you said I wonder
if that's actually better suited for an
alluvial chart that kind of diff yeah
maybe yeah what is an Olivia chart
well it seems to be it has these weights
changing over time but what is the graph
version of it
subcategory of a Sankey diagram
it's one of those things where I think
I've seen different definitions for
Sankey versus alluvial and
you know not consistent that sounds
right
um I see so this one is something where
it is like a multi-step Sankey diagram
this is a one step where it's just going
once across
and here it looks to me like it's going
well yeah except it's not it's not
exactly showing the receivers
the it's it's sort of
um you know they're not spreading every
which way
if you do an image search there are lots
of examples of multi-level Sankey
diagrams
what does that mean I'm about to find
out
I mean where you have multiple
vertical States
multiple Columns of states
I see like this
yes
I see so that's going to be a graph so
we're going to have a list of graphs
basically each one of these
regions is a graph
or this is a collection of edges this
this is a collection of edges this is
another collection of edges
right it's it's an impartite graph right
yeah it's a Cascade of yeah
we should have had these diagrams a long
time ago
and by the way this form of labeling
where you're just going into the graph
is also a thing we should have
These are nice graphs we should have had
them a long time ago as I just said
um
okay well that's the thing so I mean
there's probably a little bit of work to
be done
Brett on you know inventorying all these
different types but this is clearly you
know
good work to the AI
hats off to the bot all right let's look
at Gantt charts
these are surely worth us having
because they are common things
I guess the question is what does the
data look like for them
I mean because yeah
right it's very esoteric that's why we
had to put the project data in the name
we weren't going to allow them to name
it Gantt chart when the input was this
bizarre data set
right right I mean if you look at the
reference examples
you know your typical can't chart
there's a very clear progression over
time
well depends on the project you're doing
I mean they're usually with respect to
time I mean the respect to time but
you also
the things where like this stage
is a you know precursor to that stage
sort of thing
I don't know whether that's true I I
thought that they just had they were
just like indicating when different
things were happening
I mean maybe that's the case and maybe
that that makes it a simpler design but
yeah that's just a list of data
intervals or something yeah I think
that's what it is right yeah I think it
could be a list of lists of intervals
optionally if you want to sort of right
and you have multiple parts of a project
and right and then it should support
labels as rules probably
I think so I think this is the basic
thing I think it should also
I mean it should support values that
aren't dates
or data intervals but not mixed
sure but it should also support pairs of
numbers probably to just be coordinates
I think
sure
all right I agree with the bot again
all right what's this I don't think we
need Pareto
well I mean who knows I mean the bot
suggested it so
but yeah we've had a version in the
package for a long time no pretor
principle
you're plotting the outer hole
so to speak no that's a different thing
no no no no no no no no I mean Pareto
Principle plot is completely different
from Pareto plots
okay what is greater participator plot
it's a bar chart with an accumulated
line plot
I don't think
I don't think so either
I mean that will be a fine wfr but at
most that
and I think poor paretto would be
horrified by what people have attributed
to his name
okay Venn diagrams these are things that
come up with considerable frequency
this is by far the most often one the
GDP makes up by follow well interesting
it just takes a list of sets and
correct itself
which is not what we're doing here what
we're doing here is symbolic
I
understand what
it is
oh so it's gonna so it won't be the
circles it'll be
I mean it'll be circles for
one or two things I mean two or three
things
and then all this weird stuff right so I
I don't understand what the inputs and
outputs are when you start talking about
finite sets I mean right it should be
Union and intersection I would have
thought
and what it would be is that
a b c d and the sets are a list of
elements
right but then what is it showing
yeah it's like it's just like a
characteristic function right the things
that are included who who intersects
with whom
well
okay Michael that's still yeah I mean I
know what a Venn diagram is but a Venn
diagram just a representation of the
possible inclusions and exclusions it is
not the data dependent
well this is an example there
but those are unions and intersections
again the shape depends on it
depends on what like as you may have sea
circus then there are multiple possible
event diagrams the three circuits can be
distinct two of them can be overlapped
so it can be one can open up this one
the third one is only this one other one
and also the overlap there are plenty of
possibilities
well this looks like a more of a more
reasonable picture this is the ones
where this is showing the elements in
the set
you know this is showing the elements
that are only in this set
this is showing the elements common to
those two sets Etc but this is a typical
because every intersection is non-empty
that's not the typical case okay fine
but so but that's the that's the
ultimate way when we draw it if one has
three things
I mean there's nothing to prevent you
know right that if that c were moved
exactly exactly and then yeah you'd have
an empty intersection and you can still
depict it this way it's clear enough I
think this is not what people want
how do they want it how do they display
empty sets if it's empty they don't want
the intersection to be shown area how do
you do this
you can't of course you can you just
cannot use circles anymore right well
okay fine what shapes can you use do we
have design diagram function deal with
that
you'll notice that everyone there pretty
much seems to be a circle
one approach is to just show I like this
approach here this seems like a good
thing to do
you know you could imagine Flags say you
can imagine all kinds of things well
okay I I think the part of the issue is
that we have two
different uses for Venn diagram
one is
you know a Venn diagram of some symbolic
logical operation
you know a union B intersect C
yeah whether whether whether which is
what's in the notebook yeah I know but I
think that's a minority case that's
symbolic Venn diagram it's not what
people are usually thinking of
right and then the other cases where you
have
sets of concrete elements
you know you you have like three three
lists each of them containing some
subset of you know countries
and you want to know which countries are
in you know
you know which you know shared between
you know
split by type of government or religion
or something right that actually we can
combine these two ideas because you can
label
you know in this case here we're
probably labeling your Russian alphabet
Russian Greek Roman Latin alphabet right
and so those three things can have
labels just like these have labels ABC
yep
so really it's the same thing so what
we've got here are
you know we've got a collection of okay
here's what I claim
one thing we might have is just a you
know Venn diagram
of a collection of sets
so it's making sense hold on we can kill
a second
yes that's right it's a collection of
sets right ABC
you know c d
I
d i j or something d i j k whatever it
is right
that's three sets
and that will be a ternary Venn diagram
so to speak with three circles and we
would show where things overlap now now
presumably just like we do for other
things we can say you know
um you know X goes to this and so on to
name these things
right so that that thing goes to X
sorry that thing goes to X right or an
association you're right
I mean chat we're getting these from
chat gbt I mean do we know what what
people have been asking chat gbt for
what kind of inputs yeah yeah this is
what they this was
exactly what Stephen Ford in the first
slide sets sets of elements
okay so so that's the thing I put in
could support the thing on the first
line as well right
I'm regretting using strings for the
keys already
but uh yeah this should just be symbols
um as long as you're not calling to
expression them on on them so what
happens when you're type in a chat
instead of typing in a notebook
is this work this doesn't work does it
no no no no this is what I'm proposing
for a design the second argument
says what the highlighting is
basically and
I see
and then an option just to whether to do
what Michael is suggesting where it's
non-circles if needed and I I think that
technically called Euler diagrams
nobody knows that
actually got quite a few Wiki it's not
making it if you look at images and the
first if you just want the pure logical
thing the first argument could be an
empty list or an empty Association and
it would work and I don't think that the
logic thing is the common case I think
the common case right right I mean the
most common case
right where it's just data just sets
there's no labels that's the most common
use case in it but yeah
a handful of well you know like what
eight or whatever
logical operators we can detect the head
yes for that that's okay but I mean
you're suggesting that I should look up
Euler diagram yep
what happens when you get to more than
five things I mean how how far are we
gonna go can you're out of luck I think
up to 12 is done you know what okay I
think that papers to do it up to dress
don't you hit the Four Color limit a
little bit sooner than that
like at five
so anyway
stand wagon actually has
you know a paper about Venn diagrams yep
um and I forget what the condition is
um there's a condition on under what
that under which circumstances you can
have
a Venn diagram
which uses the same shape for all the
regions
and it goes way more than 12.
um but the shapes get really weird
but
um
right but I mean more than three it
can't just be circles
I understand
but so so okay so we will need some
I mean the question is do we have a
different head from Venn diagram and
Venn diagram I mean Venn diagram for
more than three copy circles anyway so
the only question is whether we
do what um
uh Bob was suggesting and you know just
have an option for whether to distort it
to avoid empty sets
Michael does that make sense to you
yeah
I think we've got a very nice function
here these are good these are good
suggestions I mean my gosh these are
better than we've had from I mean you
know it's like let the Bots take over
because this is these are these are good
ideas
I mean they do a lot of Coach fighting
every day
well and they also read a lot of stuff
people have written so
okay let's get these as soon as we can
these seem like high priority things
okay just a second I'm going to send you
a link
stands Pages out of date so
it's a second can I share for a moment
uh okay well yeah no it's better if you
send it to me
um
well it's an image search that came up
in the
image isn't on the page so
um I'll send you a screenshot
okay I sent it
and
what form email or something yeah email
okay
AMS article has some beautiful pictures
that may be the one maybe probably
so that's what the heck is that
that's a Venn diagram on like probably a
30 or 40
sets
well that's what's Stan with his early
life in bonak tusky Paradox land yeah I
was thinking that right you know I mean
so it's you know some weird shape that
you know is able to intersect itself in
a way so that you have all two to the n
H sure combinations
so you're saying it really is circles
only they've been you know split into a
finite number of parts in rearranged
yeah or topologically it's a circle yeah
okay this is land
um that's very cool
and certainly something we can make some
yourself
um
okay uh great let's go to our last item
here
these were these were really good
okay let's look at Geo intermediate
whatever that is don't don't you think
chat GPT deserves a raise for that
already pretty expensive but you in the
media it's also for GDP yes so it
started with geometpoint oh dear
and we decided to add an argument so
that it would do interpolation from 0 to
1.
and so I'm proposing that before we do
that we do a little extension to Geo
displacement so that we can multiply it
by numbers
and this is implemented in the X column
multiply the displacement by numbers yes
so displacements cannot be added so
there's not a full algebra of additions
of Geo displacements because they depend
on where you start I understand but you
can multiply them by numbers so that the
number would not change the direction
for positive multiplications they would
change the distance you Traverse
and if it's a negative number then they
they it's like a it's yeah I see
I mean there is a a vector addition
where you could say
transport this the the base of this
displacement to somewhere else isn't
there
well the base is not in the displacement
the displacement only knows how much to
transverse and in which direction then
we have zero destination to give a an
initial point
right there I mean or you're saying this
is then disembodied this is merely the
displacement Vector exactly it can it
computes the displacement from here to
London but the result doesn't have
neither the position of here or the
position of London I see
okay and now with your destination we
could save your destination of here and
that your displacement and we would get
back London
right so an easy way five it will give
us the midpoint along that line exactly
yep so now there is this function Geo
intermediate
which good video midpoint with t equals
0.5
we have that now
in the X kernel if you evaluate that
definition
then it works
okay
okay but what are you proposing you're
proposing I'm proposing that we extend
your displacement to be multipliable by
numbers and then it's very easy to
create
uh but do we need the function
geo-intermediate I I think so for for
what comes next
so so what are those numbers are those
like a distance and angle with respect
to a line of latitude
or
sorry sorry no Geo displacement takes a
distance emitters and an angle in
degrees from North
okay yep that's a convention
so by the way when we do the spherical
analogs of this
we may we probably need some spherical
analog of this where that's distance on
the unit sphere and that's in radians
and so on right
yeah so so can you evaluate the
geo-intermediate definitions that we can
play then
well particularly if I go to move this
the X kernel yes oh oh so sorry I
thought this was the X candle okay but I
didn't do that correctly
so the idea is you suggested in the last
meeting and this is where we left it
that we look at the basier constructions
and so what I'm proposing here is that
we can extend this Construction
to Basia curves
on the sphere and on the asphyroid
actually
oh my gosh what did I suggest
yeah so so that we look at BCA
constructions the second so we were
looking at how to what would be the
right function the right construction
and with the c occurs we can get
intermediate points by by providing a a
t value so I'm trying to imitate that
and so the interesting idea is that
there is this second definition you
intermediate of a mult of a list of
points
and this is It's recursive so we do
the intermediate of most the
intermediate of rest and then another
Gene intermediate with the with the
result of those two so so this is the
basic
definition for Basia
actually I think it was found by
somebody else the The Castle View
another French
let me see if I can't evaluate these
a person am I running here
oh
but this is strictly with respect to our
claims on the Jared
yes
so is this going to
what the heck what do you do if the Geo
positions have different heights
so
um yeah so so that is a way of getting
the point at uh fraction t
yes I see
so now the thing is if we had three
points instead of two points then we
could do some sort of bestier
construction
and you see it it
starts at the first one it ends at the
second one but it's doing some sort of
quadratic interpolation in that case
because
it didn't hit the second one it didn't
it just the last one sorry I'm counting
zero one two so the the this the first
and the third I should have said yes
so this is the the basically if this was
really confused people
wow I think people would expect this was
along the pass yeah
why don't we wanted to go along the path
I'm I'm just trying to imitate what the
sea curves do
I mean if the secrets do not go through
that intermediate Point why did we have
a okay because don't go through points
no no I know that I know they go to the
first and the last yeah
right
but why do we want that for these
geo-intermediates I don't understand
that so did you intermediate
function takes two points in there in
the in the first argument right and so
the discussion last time was what
happens if we have more points in the
first argument and that's why we say
okay let's look at this here
and and so what what I'm saying here is
that I found this way of generalizing
this year from the plane to the to the
ellipsoid
and it has the same I think that's
magnificent but I think as Michael says
it's utterly confusing to people
and we can keep it with two points yeah
well either that or go along the paths
but to all on the path would be what the
black curve is doing just geodesics from
one to another and so there are
the fact that it's not smooth at the
intermediate point
I don't know why you want it to be
smooth why would you want it to be
smooth if if this curve had many points
and the points were relatively close to
each other then this would be a
construction that gets close to all the
points and Smooths at all the points
well I mean I could imagine that we have
some kind of interpolation order-ish
type thing for geo-intermediate
so can you go to the last section or
yes so here here you here you see for
example the the two situations we have
so we have there four points in the
black curve
then we have the in red we have this new
uh
Construction
of of
the of of of a c a curve
and then in blue we have what would be
the VCR curve in flat computations with
the oppositions and so if we change the
the um the projection then the red curve
doesn't change so you see it still goes
through Cuban through England through
Finland but the blue curve is very
different
what is the red curve mathematically
it's it's the visia Curve computed on
the
um it's the image of of the busy curve
in the coordinate space in real space
yeah right so it's a three-dimensional
bezier curve now projected onto the Geo
now projected with the projection that's
used for the for the geoprojection
there's nothing 3D here it's a
computation purely done on the aspheric
but changing from the euclidean geometry
to the spheroidal okay okay but but is
that equivalent to doing the bezier
construction in 3D no no no
in the flat coordinates right it's
basically no there's nothing flat in
that competition
there is this
recursion which is the basis of the
basic construction and I'm just changing
the recursion to be done on this product
but didn't you say that the first one is
doing it
the blue curve is is contains flat
computations on the projected space
that's why it's not geometric you see
how much it changes from one projection
to the other
right oh I see I'm sorry I was confused
which curve we were talking about right
so the blue one is the one that uses
flat computation as a standout ones and
that we always had by just using the
Circ with the opposition points
but but what I'm trying to say is that
the blue curve never went through the
points themselves it never went through
Buenos Aires yeah
but it wasn't geometric it wasn't a
properly computed
a uniquely defined curve that is well
defined for all projections and the red
car is
right
okay so this is just a generalization I
found while trying to design this new
intermediate points so if it's too too
complicated which is
a two-point case for now
yep although I mean look look here's a
very standard situation which
it isn't really I mean what we're really
going to want is a plane is flying from
Waypoint to Waypoint on gd6 let's say
plane is flying from this point to that
point
yep I guess we assume they're gd6 it
might not be jd6 but but let's assume
that and then at each Waypoint it knows
it got there at 1 23 PM or something
yep
so it's going to wind up being a Time
series you know a geo-intermediate Time
series
I think that something is this one is
the pure geometry without time
okay but why does it have a t parameter
because it's the distance
it's a fraction yes
yes this is right yeah you're making the
point
go ahead yeah it's traditionally called
T sometimes s but it's basically the
fraction between one point and the other
yeah
together
right right fair enough okay and then
there's a separate Geo Time series
yes we were planning a geotra uh
trajectory that would take dates and and
know what to do I mean could we split
the difference between the very
confusing multi-point geo-intermediate
and bezier by somehow sticking busier
curve into
the second argument of geo-intermediate
or I guess I have to run off here
unfortunately I as you predicted this
this topic is not quite as simple as we
expected maybe we should uh talk about
this again in connection also with Geo
trajectory which that's good you're
gonna have similar relation you know
issues
okay okay all right I should run thanks
a lot guys see you all soon okay bye
wow
foreign